everybody's Gary Vaynerchuk another
episode of pod sessions awesome scene I
just walked into there's like 30 people
in my office
it was buzzing exactly how I love it I
sat down and [ __ ] got quiet so I'm
freaking out I'm excited to get the the
noise a little bit louder three
phenomenal guests again I will let them
introduce themselves in a second and and
actually I'm just gonna go right through
I was gonna make a comment about my
shitty fantasy baseball team but nobody
needs to hear my troubles and so let's
move on let's go ladies first why don't
we give the audience that's listening a
little bit of an origin story so who you
are what you're about actually let's
start with who you are what you what
you're up to and then I'll take it from
there awesome yeah Anastasia and I've
been surfing my whole life I've been a
professional surfer for the last
20-something years I traveled around the
world
I don't be actively anymore but what
hours did you compete how old from five
years old did you know up until last
year I'm 31 so yeah it's been a great
ride and throughout this whole time I've
always like been producing my own videos
doing photos for sponsors and brands
even when I was a young kid and you know
really started popping off with me with
social media and being able to have my
own platform and so now I get to do what
I've always loved doing is surf videos
fun photos traveling and really social
media has been great for me so and where
do you live now I live actually in
Florida now yeah you grew up where I'm
from Hawaii in California so I've
definitely yeah I've definitely been in
a everywhere tropical warm beach town
you want to get out of the west coast or
was Florida for business reasons or any
other personal my boyfriend brought me
there but I you know I'm always on the
road so it's kinda nice it's a nice home
base to come home do awesome yeah my guy
Rob Nell played professional lacrosse
going to my sixth year from New York
grew up here originally I played for New
York lizards and Team USA so heading
into the world games are the big thing
looking forward to this that's every
four years right
excited can't wait yeah you've done that
once before is this your first 2014 we
lost the Canada so your best yeah we
pissed a little bit chip-chip our
shoulder but yeah in Israel in July use
it and how you feeling about this run
feeling good don't confident you know
and new team the coach just can't not
gonna be alright again it'll be great
yeah they're always talented and who's
emerged in the last four years in your
opinion on the world stage
anybody else you got your eye on of like
that's gonna be real confident I think
team Israel they're hosting but they I
think they can maybe challenge the
Iroquois for that bronze medal Australia
is always always there but Israel in the
past hasn't been that great and I think
for most experts it's gonna be us you
guys in Canada yeah I think only one
other time it hasn't been us or Canada
in the finals so so you're focused on
Canada and uh um and what kind of brings
you here obviously Tyler is a huge
lacrosse player Paul or like you've
hacked your way but and from a business
standpoint and things of that nature
where's your mindset at I think the
unique thing about the lacrosse world is
that we're professional athletes but
we're not paid like other night so he
had to find other ways to to make a
living and I think the social landscape
has allowed us to you know guys like
myself guys like Paul to do it full-time
so it's challenging but you got to find
ways to get creative and you know most
guys are professionally you're going
into another job I'm lucky that I've
building a brand that I'm able to do it
full-time
so getting creative whether it's
developing my own platform for
instruction online for kids to watch
videos you know doing workout videos on
social media that kids want to follow
along just kind of building my brand
over years and kind of feel myself right
now more focused on it you know more
than ever so good for you man Bob's yeah
what's up everybody I'll be Marcus I'm
the founder CEO of company called on it
which is one of the leaders in human
performance we call it total human
optimization yeah and I put all that
knowledge from working with the best
people in the world a lifetime of
experience and
clinical research and put that into a
new book called own the day own your
life which is compressing all of these
practices for total human optimization
into one single day it's a big fat book
a big fat book like I feel like you
yapped a little bit too much a lot
there's a lot to the game my friend name
respect nice chapter covers a different
section of the day from waking up to
having sex to go into sleep to what you
should eat breakfast lunch dinner the
whole thing so having a glass of wine
tries to cover like a real life day
rather than just a health book that's
gonna have everybody but when is his
head tomorrow April 17 17 so week from
this recording and are you nervous are
you excited man I paid the blood price
for this book so I'm not nervous you
know I did everything I could
so at that point when you do your best
you lay it all in the line like yeah you
can't be tied to the expectations of
what it does there was not a single
point where I had a chance to rewrite or
a chance to put my best effort in and I
didn't do it so I laid it on the line so
whatever happens happens Congrats
brother it's such a they're like
children like they definitely are
special I'm excited it's here I'm
excited for people to get to know you
more in this session so let's go back
around the room and this is my favorite
part of the pod sessions I want to know
what you're currently obsessed with um
and when I say that I prefer that it not
be in like what your life is about or
what you care about like I don't I don't
want a breeze answer to be all obsessed
with maximizing your one look like I
want it to be something ridiculously
small like like this new t-shirt that
you just got that like somebody gave you
that's so [ __ ] soft you don't know
how you ever lived without it or like a
new Netflix show or like some new food
or restaurant that opened by you
something so you know I think it's
really interesting the way we live our
lives like how some little thing becomes
a new current obsession so let's go back
around what is your current obsession I
have a couple go ahead and my current
obsession right now and I don't know
where why I got so into this is
basically whenever I'm traveling I just
love watching on Instagram stories from
cities different cities even if I'm not
even traveling I'm home like okay all
want to know what's going on at this
hotspot around the world and like watch
I like watching real time real people on
the internet not necessarily like
influencers or celebrities like real
real time people and will it be as macro
as like Coachella or no no no I'd be
something like I'm just curious what the
[ __ ] happening in Des Moines Iowa
right now yeah like no like I'd say like
somewhere else we're like like you know
I like Paris or like you know London or
just yeah it doesn't need to be like a
cultural event like Coachella like
snooze like I have seen enough hipster
outfits you know it's like but lighting
the flowers of yeah yeah like yeah I've
been a Coachella ten times although I'm
coach shelled out but ya know just like
random cities and other things and then
my also other obsession recently which
actually happened yesterday I was
telling my friends that I I just swooped
some like new you know redone or brought
back like la gear stuff I was like yeah
and always like this is so tight like I
love that yeah yeah what did you get
and I got some like just crop top shirts
and like those like your lights yeah I
want to get those Natick eBay maybe
maybe so we made yeah love that I like
your perfect perfect answer oh man um
short term I'd say this weekend was the
Masters okay cause my favorite sport so
you were just like getting Thrall mm
like whole weekend dialed in Thursday or
dialed in Saturday Sunday Thursday
Friday Saturday Sunday like you just
were not productive like Tyler wasn't
super bad to me like the like my my
Empire was struggling I get myself
another boss but yeah I was
as I was you know livestream on my phone
with a boys text like did you bet did
you bet on some I didn't bet on the
masters so did you were you look do you
have a court guy or two or grunt gal
golf friend yeah so my buddy and I
played on Saturday played 18 holes then
watched before training camp started and
then some day so you guys are just
texting each other and be like holy [ __ ]
look what Jordan just did this whole
absolutely few guys I have like that but
it's a master announcer that's super
awesome that that's been really
interesting for me to watch it's clearly
like become more and more the Tiger of
fact this is gonna be so no matter how
much ESPN hypes no matter when the true
34:30 or movie doc comes out about the
tiger effect on pop culture but like
literally you know just being 42 being
in that zone where Tiger kind of like
came up but also being in the wine
business as a kid and mainly hanging out
with high net-worth individuals that
were in their 40s to 80s like just
watching in one generation the
interesting Golf becomes so much younger
and now you've got this whole new kind
of group of guys who like go to Baker
you know and that's kind of like just
drink marry you so show and like do
ridiculous guy things has created a wave
but it's really interesting how cultural
the Masters has become for people 20 to
40 instead of 40 to 80 as it was when I
was growing up as a kid absolutely
and like did you like golf as a kid yeah
my dad hadn't clubbed my hand I was
three years old so I love it there's a
lot of young sports going on around here
yeah Club and hand a three on a surfing
professionally a five yeah it's pretty
gnarly top yeah I would say one thing
that's been interesting is did a lot of
research on tobacco for the book and as
a performance enhancer and I started
getting into Swedish snus which is one
of the cleanest forms of like a chewing
tobacco okay and that that to me has
been so you get mouth cancer
well it depends obviously frequency
there's some risk there's some risk
involved but Royal London College of
Physicians
it's like ten to a thousand times safer
than smoking cigarettes or something
like that and nicotine itself isn't
really the issue a lot of the associated
things with tobacco and the Swedish
noose is one of the cleaner versions I'm
not saying there's no risk what I'm
saying as far as I'm saying like maybe
four times a week but it's probably my
favorite drug because you feel amazing
amazing I mean I've experienced lift
people know me and follow me I've
experienced a lot of the psychedelic
drugs a lot of the things if I had to
probably say all right no more drugs no
more caffeine no more alcohol no more
sugar in there no sugar no nobody's very
drugged like I just get rid of that I
remember something I said about like you
so Ivan I'm the reverse I've never I've
ever done any drug I've never tried any
tobacco product in my life outside of
literally alcohol I could [ __ ] blow
your mind right now gay I got it I got a
Swedish snus funny I think I need like I
need to go the other way bro I like like
I have so much natural adrenaline and hi
like it's so amazing to me how I never
gravitated towards that I think my mom
was also super super brainwashed by
Nancy Reagan and like like no more drugs
or say no or whatever [ __ ] that wasn't
the 80s but um actually the true answer
isn't that you'll find this interesting
for everybody listening my mom grew up
in Soviet Russia where won the Soviet
Union was so miserable that most people
died at 62 there was no health like you
know the amount of vodka consumed in
that country is just so overwhelming so
my mom basically saw every male figure
she knew ever outside of like one
grandpa like drink themselves into
oblivion
that's like a norm like it's really
funny when I got to college you know in
high school it was drinking culture of a
college like got like a lot of my
buddies like I'll just never forget like
my my wedding rehearsal night my uncle's
dismantled my friends like it was just
the best scene I'd ever seen all my
buddies who thought they could drink
like my uncle's drank
Ali
of great use to the face every single
normal holiday like it was like
literally a half a bottle of vodka was
the equivalent to normal Americans
having a glass of champagne like as an
aperitif like so I think my mom was
super affected and like kind of pushed
me in the other direction but it's it's
really really really interesting to me
because I do think on the flip side I'm
always fascinated by what the
establishment has made a negative versus
a positive the way I think about school
the way think about a lot of things I
actually subconsciously understand that
truth around most drugs and things of
that nature so for example I'm very fast
I'm unbelievably undereducated when I
make this statement because I don't need
to get destroyed on on in the comments
section and have to spend an hour like
you know context ting it I say this with
full transparency I'm super under
educate on everything about that world
but I am fascinated intuitively around
steroids for example like it always runs
through my mind that like hmm like
what's the real punchline they're like
you know next time we hope you're
dunking a basketball so that that has
become huger and what's the subculture
around what's a call to get one more
time snus s NUS and so what's going
what's the what's the underbelly it's
kind of like why it's it's biohacker
it's people trying to find the cleanest
way to deliver the nicotine which is
it's a really interesting feeling when
you push the boundary because it starts
off kind of excitable like you get a
little energy like a stimulant and then
everything gets really heavy and quiet
almost like you're spearfishing at the
bottom of the water when everything gets
really still I mean you've probably done
that before it's like this crazy feeling
that'll settle over your body and that's
the part that's really enjoyable because
for me I'm a little bit like you My
Mind's always running and this actually
takes you beyond that point and it kind
of drops you in how much do you like
being in control a lot so do you how do
you think about drinking drugs like like
to me the thing that I you know as you
were talking the thought of going
mundane or like like being in the bottom
of Experian one of the things that's
been interesting to me is well I've not
been drunk a lot in my life and I grew
up in the alcohol business you know I'm
I grew up in America like like I think
about the reason why no question for me
the the reason I don't like you know
asking for things that a lot of my
content lately has been about this I've
realized and it just summed up as you
were talking my greatest angst the thing
I hate the most is not being in control
the reason I never like the reason I
love running my own [ __ ] is I do not
want to be at the mercy of anything but
myself and one of the reasons I've not
liked being drunk or getting into any
zone is I don't like not being in
control what I could see one arguing
that is control I'm fascinated by that
but you said you love being in control
yeah I mean for me I love having a
couple drinks but in moderation and you
know I social have a drink to you but
like you all do you agree with me that
if you're off you know your rocker and
or mellowed out the death feel of do you
feel less in control yeah a hundred
percent like but when you're surfing
though I mean in that state it is a
state of being out of control I mean
it's a state of surrender naturally
right like you get out of your head
completely well I feel like you were
intensely you are in control but you are
dealing with an uncontrollable element
understood yeah so you can't but that's
life yeah exactly I'm in control I know
I yeah you know Seth might punch me in
the [ __ ] face right yeah prepared at
all times like yeah and with a pink hat
me stab me in my neck
yeah I'm always aware of what's
happening and you know how do you feel
the same way I think you know everything
affects people differently so you know
you talk about experimenting with
different things you know I have and
you've you feel out of control and
you're like I don't want to do that
again it's probably the reason why I
don't do certain things as much as other
people do it
I don't drink a ton you know I if I'm if
I drinking
I'm going out and like drinking I'm not
just like half your binary I'm not
having you're not gonna be casual on
that one that's like you know yeah very
rare okay go home he needs to keep an
eye on you yeah uh you watch me play
lacrosse to me no it's not that bad
people will tell you that they think I'm
always in control like they've never
seen me crazy out of control when I go
out but I'm not I think I'm just always
you know the captain in college always
overlooking the team when we were out
you know at the fraternity you know so I
always had to make sure everything was
gonna be okay if you watch me play
lacrosse I kind of operated like 80%
speed I'm never you know full even well
I think it's like laying I don't want to
get myself into position at all I kind
of pathetic
yeah so I wanna be in control so up do
you put when you go there with you know
experimenting things are you conscious
before you go there to put yourself in a
position where you're controlled at home
or no hundred percent so like I I think
being unconsciously out of control is a
horrible idea
whether you're partying or whether
whatever if you're unconsciously out of
control that's terrible but there is so
much [ __ ] magic in super conscious
surrender I'm so like if you're doing a
psychedelic or if you're just completely
allowing yeah something to happen like
there's real magic on the blue field
feel the magic of that plays out back in
the quote-unquote real world because you
have the context of the - yeah
absolutely and then then when that
uncontrollable element happens you've
practiced and you've trained the art of
completely letting go and not resisting
the irresistible force yeah you know and
so it helps you get over these emotional
issues that you would normally obsess
over and helps you move beyond and see
the assistance that's coming on the back
side of the resistance what what's
happening in that subculture like
obviously you know our friend Tim
Ferriss and others like it would be
obvious to me just living in culture
that there's huge momentum in in the in
the kind of like that 20 to 30 year old
alpha male acceptance of psychic
Daleks and experimental that is far more
accepted right now in my opinion in what
are you seeing in the subculture like
what would that were two or three years
for it feels like it's two three years
four years into this what do we see
a lot of a lot of high performers myself
included are deeply unhappy on certain
levels with ourself in some particular
way we're super driven and we catalyze a
lot of that energy from early trauma and
early yeah expectations we couldn't live
up to and we catalyze that and in the
outward exertion of you know effort as
an entrepreneur a lot later I'm 37
so sober 20 but the the deep unhappiness
that we feel these are tools to allow us
to get down to the roots of that and
start pulling the weeds and healing the
cracks in the foundation and I think
that's what's driving people to feel
like what are you in that state you're
able to have that conversation with
yourself [ __ ] yeah
like see little things that were blind
to me you know patterns that develop for
my parents things that I've been driven
by pleasing this certain person or
living up to this expectation and
unravel you've gone and talked with you
have you gone that route as well yeah
you can't talk about what you can't see
you know so you can talk like oh yeah
you know I think things were pretty good
but you're blind you're blind until you
become aware of what it is and then you
can start talking and then allow people
experts psychiatrists other people to
help you clean up you know what you
became aware let me uh let me use this
as a building block to change the
conversation but actually build right on
top of that as three performers this is
super interesting to me what you just
said I'm fascinated by the last 20 years
of parenting so I think it is in America
and I've seen parts of Asia I just don't
have enough context house outside but in
America over the last 20 years I feel
like the parenting has and this is a
very blanket statement but I'm fat
enough that I'm starting the foundations
of the book I've been yelling about for
years called perfectly parented I'm
super fascinated by that cup not the
coddling but it's really one thing you
know like parents
but when there's abundance parents will
always do this during good times even
look at parents parenting during the
roaring 20s like you know when things
are good you know you start worrying
about dumb [ __ ] like when you have
nothing you worry about food and shelter
you do not worry about how long you
waited for your uber and [ __ ] why did it
go around the block again you know like
like you you know it's just life you
worry about you know what my parents
when they first came to America when we
live in this studio apartment the size
of this they were worried about certain
[ __ ] they were about their [ __ ] now it's
just normal so after three generations
of abundance in America but obviously
this is a net America there's obviously
Mississippi has not been crushing it for
the last three generations or most of it
unfortunately which is a whole nother
obsession of mine Mississippi but I
haven't really talked about I'm very
fascinated by parents trying to protect
kids from losing like in a big way like
especially now that I'm a parent just
watching parents talk about things like
we have to invite everybody to the
birthday party you know just like stuff
that is so ridiculous to me as three
competitors and it sounds like you
started athletic super early and I'm
projecting but I think you did as well
right
do you feel like that was a great thing
for you did your parents try to actually
manipulate some not losing did you see
it what is your three opinions on this
notion very simply that losing a lot
young is actually the great advantage to
life not a disadvantage that I think
parents have unbelievably net-net
tried to protect kids from losing we've
changed so much of our athletics in the
u.s. you know we don't have like keeping
score into like [ __ ] fifth grade I
mean it's just it's real intense since
it's gotten very it's a very interesting
conversation and to me you start talking
about unwinding things look kids have to
unwind alcoholism and abuse and a lot of
hardcore stuff that you can't predict or
things that nature watching the country
and I'm talking about the liberal and
the conservative that I love when I
bring this up a lot of the homies from
like you know
alibi
like yeah you [ __ ] New York in LA
homies Gary go get him I'm like bro you
know like I'm weird when somebody hits
me up on Twitter and says yeah you're so
right the New York LA liberal [ __ ] get
him Gary I love you I look at their
accountant like okay this town in
Arkansas I like Google and look up the
rules of their soccer league and then
like reply to them be like yo dude your
league has [ __ ] 8th place trophies
too so this is like a net thing what is
what is your 2 cents 3 cents on this
whole conversation yeah I mean I I
thousand percent agree I mean like the
way I was brought up it was like either
you're a winner or you're a loser and it
worked I mean like for me to like I
remember I used to cry I was so
emotional about getting second place and
about and I because it was either you
know you win or you lose and you know
they didn't know they were like well you
didn't win right cry yeah they were like
they were like yeah you know you better
next time I cried basically minimum ly
once a week for the first 13 years of my
life yeah this is not a joke I would cry
all the time yeah I just cried every
time I lost yeah like until I was 9 I
cried it every time I lost like dead
tears like death tears yeah I leave
point where like nobody really wanted to
play with me and I could tell when
people are letting me win and that would
make me cry too
so just crying ya know and for me too I
thought it was very interesting when I
was a young kid because I was like
obsessed with getting first in every
event and when I would go over to my
friends houses that had participation
trophies and trophies in their room and
I was always like what like what what
place does this you were wrong like did
they think you were too much seriously
oh yeah yeah growing up like I mean
that's to learn how to coddle that a
little bit yeah I mean if we did I was
doing like the thing when I was like 12
13 I was doing shoots for like teen
magazine and I was like coming up and
you know getting attention and stuff and
that was also weird too like I wasn't
bullied but people were definitely like
oh like you're special
yeah what also - when I was growing up
surfing wasn't cool for girls so that's
a whole other thing but it was like oh
like you know you're you're like a dude
you're like a tomboy like you're not
cute like oh you know yeah there's a lot
of that stuff but um yeah you care are
you so deep into I don't think that you
didn't give a [ __ ]
I will try no that never made me cry
lose email I love it yeah but for you I
think it starts with parenting I mean I
almost didn't play College across
because I wasn't recruited like I didn't
have many options to go to school at one
point I had no options you know my fifth
year of high school trying to go
somewhere but I think it was because of
how I joined fifty or high school I
wasn't recruited so I took a post-grad
year at a prep school so you were that
hardcore yeah and now that's where I
thought you were yeah I think so you
were that religious of like [ __ ] their
son playing lacrosse yeah
I think that's from my dad when I was
younger he like it was all about being
you know the best you can be and being
the best and winning and you know I was
I was do but I wonder that's such an
intense year yeah like like I can't even
think of anybody I know that took a
[ __ ] fifth year of high school to
like to me why didn't you accept that
the market said you weren't good enough
like because it was still one more
option and you needed to like scratch
that itch I'm curious in the psychology
of like nobody would like it feels like
I mean this when I say this I really
don't think I know I don't know for
anybody you like I'd love for anybody to
shake their head like I don't even know
anybody who ever took a fifth year of
high school to get into a sport like
that's that's an intense jump yeah it
was I had that love lacrosse I had that
dream of playing Division 1 lacrosse at
the highest level possible playing a
Memorial Day in the national
championship and when that wasn't
happening I was like okay what do I need
to do differently to be better and I
kept you know working working but so
much time and effort when did when did
it set in that wasn't happening late
junior year I'd say my my senior year I
wanna say I was recruited like division
three division to understand I'll not
though we're not talking Hopkins
that's exactly exactly I'd say my junior
to senior year and I was committed to a
Division one school that was you know
outside the top 50 and I was like okay I
this is
my last push to make this happen I had a
great so you had a hedge like late June
you're going to scout ahead
you had ahead yeah and you're like but
I'm gonna [ __ ] dismantle it yep and
and somebody's gonna see that and swoop
in yep
and then I did that as I said I'm not
coming and I took a fifth-year at the
prep school so you did that senior year
and that didn't happen right to your top
ten school didn't come in I actually
made this decision after my senior year
so I was supposed to I made it in the
summer after senior year I said I'm not
coming and I'm sure this school yeah and
you said I'm gonna go to this prep
school I'm gonna prep school and that's
allowed uh yeah I not really signed a
contract you know I was has to be there
so technically I could only look at non
scholarship schools round oh that part I
mean that prep school like you could go
like oh so what about you go to the best
school and what happens I was talking to
a few schools they all told me they
didn't have room for me I couldn't get
me in and at one point in October the
reason I was there play Division one
lacrosse I wasn't talking to anyone and
then I don't know where Cornell came and
you gotta be red shirt different year or
like you know it was the other next year
yeah yeah and that's a it was crazy I
remember calling my mom crying Sharon
when these two other schools told me
they couldn't take me and I was like
what am I here for
and this unwraps school yeah I'm here
I'm gonna play lacrosse I'm a fifth year
senior 50-round a car I think about
where were you Deerfield Academy in
Massachusetts so you're in math yeah
Deerfield man do you feel mass all your
friends are literally like six eight
weeks into their college lives you're in
this high school I'm in a single dorm
room with you know the center of the
football team
so there was I added they added a bed
for me to get in there was just like it
was a high school yeah what am i doing
and what I'm when did Cornell call
November I went up for homecoming and
hit it off with the coaching staff it
was the coach called me back he's like
you wanted common I was like well I have
no other options so you had to do it and
I played a national championship my
freshman year at Cornell that's [ __ ]
crazy yeah so literally in October you
your your fifth year senior in in
whatever that is and literally that
spring summer you're in that you're in
the n-c-double-a $29 playing four
thousand people yeah crazy
that was intense eight months yeah oh
yeah so what did you see around you in
this highly competitive northeast
environment like you just saw a lot of
parents [ __ ] out or didn't you even
realize it was happening you're a kid
yeah yeah dad's yelling like like just
like lack of self-awareness like dads
like a kid that you knew suck [ __ ] like
in junior high that had no prayer cuz he
didn't have the size or speed or a scale
but his dad when you came over like
literally thinks his son's gonna be at
Hopkins I think you see it today more
than ever I mean why hooah
in your perspective yeah I mean
everything that you touched on I think
it's just like that notion that parents
that they want their kids to like think
that they're gonna be this you want to
be positive think they're gonna be this
great thing I mean I would have like
five goals and little and youth Li you I
come off the field my dad would be like
you missed this one on the crease and
you missed this guy who was wide open
there I feel like that can go far the
other way I feel like that's why I'm
here today is because my dad was so
critical of me yes and do you feel like
do you think if your dad was sitting
here that if I asked him hey bro
do you think that you dad would have had
the self-awareness that your son wasn't
dealing with that well that you would
have been able to take the foot off the
pedal or do you think your dad had one
move the other way I was I think parents
most parents yeah have one move one way
or the other and I'm most fascinated by
the parent that has the ability to go to
the middle when they react to the
reality I think you versus their own
ambition yeah I think you would have I
think he saw how I reacted to it right
it was like competitive it was popular
for me should that eventually when I got
the good friends good friends that had
dad's or mom's doing the same thing that
crumbled under that yep and wanted to
punch her parent in the face
absolutely yeah my mom was a
professional tennis player so lost in
the semi finals of Wimbledon like did
the thing your mom yeah lost Billie Jean
King semi finals of Wimbledon what
[ __ ] yeah Kathleen harder
that's insane yeah so she was she was
the real deal early dude and so when I
was playing ball I was basketball player
she could beat me in tennis I was like
32 still and that was only because
mobility like strokes are still better
yeah did you just laugh at me but but I
think her experience and knowing that I
mean losing is a part of life and she
understood that and it's just how you
deal with it what you take from it but
her love never wavered when I want her
lost and I can't say the same for my dad
my dad was never a great athlete and he
was more ego invested in my performance
and I think with him you know it was a
lot tougher because he didn't really
understand what it was like to play at a
high level and and his attitude towards
me changed if I had a bad game if I
missed some shots you know then it was
like where dad go like dad doesn't give
a [ __ ] about me anymore you know or you
would like jump on me for stuff and I
was like I'm already better than you I'm
12
like you can't like what are you doing
dad so it was a balance of having both
types of parents but I think ultimately
the job of a parent is to prepare you
for life and and losing is a part of
life it's just what you do with that
loss do you use it to make you better to
use it to make you feel like you aren't
worthy of love anymore you know I'm
super fascinated by the absolute value
of losing I'm just super into it and I'm
just I'm just shocked by the lack of
self-awareness of parents to not to
realize it's doing such a huge
disservice I just see so many of my
friends and contemporaries like it's
just so obvious that the fear of losing
just cripples them because they never
take like it's super important to taste
that [ __ ] early on interesting and taste
and taste the the result of that you
know I mean like if the best thing that
you can do as any parent or any mentor
anybody is take the worst possible thing
the thing that's the curse the thing
that's the loss and say
yeah you know now how do you know how do
you become grateful for this you know
like how is this gonna make you better
and that you teach that that's the
[ __ ] recipe for life whatever failure
whatever loss whatever curse whatever
hardship you know use that thing to make
you that much stronger teach that [ __ ]
do you feel that you're over-reliant on
Instagram
so this is something I want to spend a
lot of time on it's the first time I'm
bringing it out super important for me I
believe net-net listening to you know
I've got a better sense for you and I
think you're more diversified you know
as people are clearly trying to figure
out their value in the thank God for
influencer marketing you know listen to
your two intros right do you believe
that if I said right now you know it's
really fun to critique the parents of
the world right now and we just had a
lot of fun razzing ourselves do you
believe very simple yes/no do you
believe that you're too vulnerable to
Instagram yes and no I mean that's the
thing I've done basically my same job
for 20 years or so and like he mentioned
you know we're both in unique sports
that you know right don't necessarily
they're not mainstream and I'm also
coming off of you know a career of
competing as well so yeah I mean I
retired a year ago I I still do events
but not full-time so and did that feel
weird was that like a detox or was that
gradual did you feel like that was
happening over the last three or four
years I felt like it was garage one and
like in like I mentioned I like to win
so where I felt like I couldn't dedicate
my time at the highest level yeah like I
don't want to show up to events and not
do good or not I feel like I gave it my
all so that's kind of where I was at I
lost the energy yeah but you know I
still think about it I so you know
servings in the Olympics for 2020 I mean
that's something that's is it the first
time
first time yeah and I [ __ ] I know I
already tell sorry where I cried when I
heard it got it I was like I couldn't
imagine I was like wow and this is
conniving super weird yeah it's weird it
is we're but it's well you know it was
16 or if it was 24 it would have been
better for you yeah I mean and also I
think what's interesting to me like I
mean even 1020
years ago when I was convened like we
barely had a girls tour or anything and
now it's like an Olympic sport and I'm
you know very grateful and I feel like I
contributed to a lot of you know mean
other surfers to get surfing out
meanwhile you can't help but running
through your head like [ __ ] I could have
won an Olympic gold medal yeah I just
you know you never know I mean it's on
my mind but uh but you'd have to like
legitimately like quit might quit right
like you'd have to believe actually you
should probably if you're a baby not
doing it you probably have to leave
right this second yeah I'll see you guys
here yeah yeah yeah which it runs
through my mind I'm like hmm you know on
a very serious note if you like
literally walked out of this room right
now and like went to Hawaii like start
to get your [ __ ] together you know it's
tough like you're talking about the top
these are you know yeah people undressed
by the difference between like you
fooling around with your friends and
what the like I actually think that is
one of the most fascinating things to me
in life that regular people can't
comprehend the Delta between themselves
and the tippy-top of the sport like I
always try to like with my friends like
my friends always say dumb [ __ ] like you
you don't have to like if we play like
five on five pick-up book and when you
get the right five together and you like
really feel it and then somebody says
something stupid because you won like
seven games in a row like you know if we
play the Warriors too like we're not
going to score dick winning we're not
even gonna score yeah they really tried
score in a basketball game so I think I
think that um what I always told my
friends are like bro
look at all the NCAA athletes look at
the ones that are like the seventh best
player in there in like college like at
the time that don't even make it to the
next level the Delta is so extreme do
you think that if you walked out of here
right now and started going hardcore
that you could make a real run in 2020
it would be a struggle yeah it would be
a circle and that and that and that's
where it's like because even if you knew
even if there was an if you thought you
could met all you'd probably walk out of
here right now
yeah cuz it's cool yeah yeah I mean cuz
that's the thing yeah yeah yeah I
noticed
I apologize for cutting you off I
noticed lewis howes is a quote here like
louis went to the Olympics on the
handball thing I still think it's the
funniest [ __ ] like literally when he did
that I there was one flight where I was
like what's something super random
that's in the Olympics like something
dumbest [ __ ] and that is nobody knows
like I was like looking for the hack to
get in the Olympic yeah it's just funny
innit it's amazing it got it so that's
kind of how it runs through your mind
yeah and I mean into further answer your
question yes like speaking back to like
I said rim yeah Instagram and you know
working with brands and stuff it's like
what's your second biggest platform I've
I mean Facebook's are my number one but
like I mean Facebook Instagram you know
I do them all but Twitter or snapchat
but I you know it's it's like anything
like I think every day like is it gonna
change or will it go away
yeah you know is all my say Tom
literally yesterday I know it sound like
what's up but like you know like I say
myspace time or do you just say Tom I
say both yo you're like MySpace Tom and
like this is great but like I was on
myspace back in the day I was like I was
a really geeky kid I was on the internet
like you also were building a brand of
five so yeah that makes sense
yeah do you feel like you're over
relying on Instagram yes and so like
what do you even have a number two so I
Twitter but that's like a distant -
right yeah yeah and so like how do you
think about that like do you think about
podcasts do you think about YouTube do
you yeah I think like I said right now
I'm more focused on that more than ever
yes I think I'm gonna point my life
where I'm comfortable and you want to
start getting into different things so
uncomfortable because you scratched the
edge of La Crosse are comfortable
because you're starting to get some
deals and like can see it that number
two I have some deals and I'm
comfortable where I'm at in the sport
you know I'm not you know I'm always
striving to be the best you know
confident and in my position right now
and where I am
I want to start really taking that next
step so I'm looking at podcasts YouTube
channel seeing which what I can do best
you know what I can you know do with
most consistency because I think that's
what I admire the most about people who
are in this space and you do a great is
how consistent they are and you know
you're putting out podcast every day and
that's that takes effort that takes work
so which what's my next go to platform
that I can be consistent in you know I
want to be a consistent performer like I
can be on the cross I want to do that
with what I choose next and for now
right now Instagram is the one that I
can be most consistent Oh Bravo for you
and how do you and how do you think
about you as a human versus on at the
brand that's a funny thing to kind of
reconcile at a certain point because
this birthed out of me and was just me
me and on it we're smashed together as
we get it now 180 people in there and it
it has a life of its own and it's my job
to just kind of Shepherd it and steer it
in the right ways that uphold certain
principles of mine but it's its own
thing for sure and it can get kind of
trippy to look at this thing that was
like a piece of my flesh that now has
developed into something that's no
longer what's what's the biggest
challenge of something that is a piece
of your flesh that is now a company of
180 people for you today how many years
ago did it start 2011 was really the
really so like you know what's the
biggest challenge for you I think the
baby at this point cuz I think that
you're an interesting spot I have a lot
of empathy for it I'm sure a lot of
people listening a lot of times we talk
about you know so much my content is
geared towards people that haven't
started yet or a year in your UI were
past those places in our lives I feel
like you're in a place where your
personal brand is gaining momentum mmm
right you've been focused on on it you
know I think you know listen I always
try to remind people like I built Wine
Library for the first decade before I
even put one piece of before I put now I
got lucky
let's call what it is there was no
putting out content you know back then
but there was blogs and I can't write
for [ __ ] so that helped me but MySpace I
watched very carefully Friendster
myspace I was fascinated
I didn't start content
there you know I think it's an
interesting transition when you actually
run a company and then some of the
attention goes to you and you start
realizing there's a double benefit I
mean this book is gonna be great for you
it's gonna be great for the business
yeah
do you worry about getting caught on the
drug of being the person and that then
makes you take an eye off the business
it's a it's a balance you know cuz to
write this book I can't be focused on
other stuff so you have to trust the
people that you put in place and you
have to allow some flexibility for the
company to take on some of their
personality like my CLO my CTO like they
are shaping on it in a certain way and
again that's enough talk to me about
2007 on it if we were 2011
ya know 2007 I'm sorry I apologize let's
talk about 2000 um let's talk about 2014
on it okay
on it in 2014 what percentage of your
fingerprints is on that business I mean
the whole thing 199 like in 2014 she
doesn't want every aspect every single
aspect in the coding give me a net you
hired yeah I mean well if that people on
hire we're talking like 90 92 percent of
this company I mean it's like of the 50
biggest decisions that had happened that
year how many did you forty nine right
and now in 2018 I mean now we're talking
closer to 35% and of the 50 biggest
decisions I'm still making a majority of
those maybe 40 42 understood yeah I mean
what does that feel like does that feel
do you feel back to doing a recall your
ability to go to that psychedelic place
I'm being you know it's actually it is a
little haha I'm enjoying the recall of
it but I do think it's an interesting
insight do you believe that your
escapism in that form and trying to
learn to control the uncontrollable and
you know however one would define that
sector I want to use the right
adjectives and words do you think that
has helped you let go a thousand percent
yeah cuz you you learned you learn to
have trust and you learn to and also
read deeply into the subconscious
patterns that people have because you
see them in yourself and you can see
them in other people and then because
you got to really trust the people that
you're handing over the reins to
especially for the important decisions
and so I feel like I can see them read
them I can share myself with them better
so that they understand me better so
that there's not this discrepancy of
what would Aubry say or what would I be
do they can kind of keep my spirit alive
even when I'm not there and make
decisions that would be akin to the
decisions that I would make so that's
helped and also yeah
letting go and trusting that you know
this will become what it's supposed to
become let's uh let's end on a speed
round can ask some questions everybody
answers what's the most interesting
thing happening on Instagram right now I
touched on it earlier I think the
real-time slopes
I think the real-time stories in the
geotags love it could be a single
account it could be a single person it
could be something happening in your
community yeah I don't know for me
what's the first thing you do when you
go to Instagram in the morning do you go
to your DMS do you go look at how your
last post performed do you go into
Explorer do you go through your feed
what's the first thing you do I just go
through my feet okay yeah yeah and you
like [ __ ] yeah like stuff yeah yeah I
think I think that actually that's a
good apply there I think I find
fascinating like the likes I found I
think people are just scrolling more and
liking less and it just kind of like
become a habit where you just scroll
consuming an incentive added which is
actually reading what the post is well
one of the coolest things I've watched
happen is one of the trainers in our gym
his name's private goes by primal
soldier and I watched him come up from
nothing now to like a hundred and fifty
thousand followers and he's just
swinging kettlebells and then he
launched his own training program and
with just Instagram alone in the span of
like 18 months he's got a hundred
thousand dollar business with recurring
and subscriptions and things going on
and just from being relentless and
consistent to different kettle bell
flows he's sweaty he's got his shirt off
he's got short shorts he's got black hat
he does it every single day and now I go
out to eat in Miami and I'll have like
an honest supplement on the table and
they'll be like oh [ __ ] you work with
promise Walter
it's cool to see someone use a platform
I get it indie rock you're like okay um
favorite food right now I'm really the
matcha mm-hmm drink yeah or a sigh but
that's like been my go-to yeah I'm gonna
go the beverage I really gotten into
molecular hydrogen and consuming that
consistently throughout the day it's
interesting yeah it's weird but yet it's
different now yeah I've been playing
around with exogenous ketones and that's
what I'm excited about it's something
it's the alternate energy source to
sugar for the system and it helps you
can obviously have a full ketogenic diet
which I'm a fan of but this will kind of
help bridge the gap and help you cheat a
little bit and so really playing around
with those on it doesn't have any of
those right now but I'm playing around
with them personally it's uh it's funny
though I actually have a weird one too
and I don't even know the proper name
for it but there's pop there's popcorn
that has some I don't remember the first
word but it's yeast as the topping
instead of butter I don't know if it's
like nutritional you know about this
nutritional yeast I think that's right
have you think it tastes kind of like
cheese dude it's [ __ ] amazing it's
really good like freaks me out how
delicious it is like I like it
way better than butter and like butters
the best on popcorn for me like
historically what are you binging or
consuming on Netflix or any other OTT or
HBO or what have you
nothing is a fair answer not yeah
nothing I yeah yeah that's nothing yeah
I'm and I'm excited for what will become
that yes but right now it's nothing not
nothing the last thing was peaky
blinders so I went through that oh yeah
it was that great you don't loved it I
loved it yeah it was great I don't even
know what's yeah yeah if I could if I
could wait in line and it would make
Westworld happen faster like if I could
go iphone style I might get it before
everybody else I'd [ __ ] would I love
that show I love that show
a last parting shot this where you can
promote a book or ask a question or
anything you'd like to say let's wrap it
up
this is awesome please actually gonna
bounce right now hang it what would be
better for your wall of things or things
for the office a surfboard or bikini um
a surfboard
I think okay I have something pretty
legit yeah I'm thinking about resetting
the whole thing okay perfect like me in
the center I'm thinking about super
resetting and and like really going
there with [ __ ] I care about so like for
example I have to I'm gonna go on eBay
in the next couple days like I need to
buy like 80 wrestling figures not just a
couple like I'm gonna really make it
even more personal right now people like
sneaking in and putting [ __ ] and like
trying to like it's just not enough me
and so I need to reset it but a
surfboard would be great
I do want like some anchor thing I'm
gonna do two things when I ask you
questions but first thing I wanna say is
right now I started a Instagram account
live fit 30 with Brian maza and it's our
daily workouts under 30 minutes well so
where that's putting a lot of my like
that for you as someone well thank you
this is cool actually started taking on
supplements a few weeks ago followed you
for a while um so he really really you
wanted you really yes I listen to his
podcast Tim Ferriss and and started
taking his supplements and following him
for a few weeks so it's uh is awesome at
talking about that's you know that's
second social and you know which I use
what are you yeah how do you what do you
think should go I think it's reverse
engineering what you're about look so to
me it's like if you can write I really
really believe like writing is grossly
underestimated right now like one thing
I know for a fact is most people on the
Instagram right now are grossly mailing
in the copy and focusing way too much in
the picture obviously the pictures
massive and even if it's 80% which I
would be comfortable in saying it is the
visuals eighty percent that would leave
20 percent around the copy and its
impact on the success of what are we
doing here we're trying to put out
pieces of content that give us
distribution in awareness that becomes a
gateway drug to another thing that we
want to happen whether that's to sell
supplements or sneakers or books or you
know to like I want to make more people
jet fans and make
the more aware of other like like
whatever it is I could care less of like
what you want that to be to me its if
you'd be great at the craft of getting
people to pay attention attention is the
currency and everybody is mailing in
copy so if you could write
I think blogging and copy on your posts
is super huge
I think audio subs I couldn't push
people more to starting a podcast if
they're willing to go there right like
like everybody thinks I own 0.00% of
anchor and everybody thinks I own like
all of it because I always push it only
because I know it's a very easy way for
people to start a podcast right so to me
written an audio because video and
picture has become easy and second
nature to everybody that means the
opportunity is in video excuse me in
written word and audio thank you you got
it up yeah I mean right now I'm in the
final stages this book launch and I what
are you doing on Tuesday when the book
comes out I'm gonna be signing some
books but doing a lot of face book lives
doing a lot of digital I got different
digital platforms that are hitting me up
and just trying to mail blast from home
yeah through the on enlist through my
list through everybody pod committed a
hundred percent POC committed like
there's there's no more we pushed all in
and it's great man I mean I think this
is there's nothing that's that I've ever
seen its combined the entire spectrum of
human optimization into a single place
so you don't need to go hunting for
conflicting experts we got 300 clinical
academic references and it's not about
buying a bunch of honest stuff we're
talking about the free doctors like sex
and sleep and exercise and light and
hydration how much you sleep I sleep
about seven hours and then take 30
minute nap salaat what range about one
day is your sweet spot is about my sweet
what's your sleep 16 and what a cool 16
hours on what's and what's the problem
what's the norm the net right over seven
so it's two all depending on what I fall
11 eleven twelve this hasn't got it and
for you
10 11 till six seven yep
I'm really really midnight just six or
11 to six you know or 12 I'm saying like
I the reason I wanted to jump on this
before we end it is I'm
just super sad that people think hustle
means sleep for hours just to me the
biggest problem is what are you doing
when you're awake mm-hmm
how much energy do you have I'm uh
that's the rate yeah you know that's
exactly right and like like I just I you
know it's just the black and white of
not a lot of hours like and making that
cool is such a strategic mistake and a
30-minute nap outperformed more
overnight sleep and more coffee and
clinical research so don't be afraid to
nap even if I'm fine on that you need to
know your body right like if I can't nap
like I just can't and like when I do
everything's like it just and like even
when I try to like force myself it's
like like I think any of these advices
about anything comes down to self
awareness and understanding yourself
like trying different things to figure
out that thing for you is just the game
you might want to try a caffeine nap
then where you have a little bit of
caffeine and then try a nap so you don't
go too deep because the problem with
napping and being tired is you get into
the deep phases of sleep and if you're
in the deep phases of sleep and pull
yourself out rather than being in rem or
some lighter phase there's no worse than
[ __ ] waking up don't want that you
want to wake up from the light sleep or
not even go down that deep in a nap just
just just touch the surface of that
theta brainwave state guys thanks woody
no thank you
[Music]